[Music]
hey everyone how are you doing today
so in Harry Potter we've all seen the
handsome young man that was Tom Marvolo
riddle the orphan boy who turned into
he-who-must-not-be-named now Voldemort's
body and face changed drastically over
time we can see this in the films and of
course for those who read the books we
have read it in every book as well
Voldemort's appearance is constantly
compared to that of a snake slits for a
nose slits for eyes and so on in the
half-blood prince
let's check this piece of text Voldemort
had entered the room his features were
not those Harry had seen emerged from
the great stone cauldron almost two
years before they were not as snake-like
the eyes were not yet scarlet the face
not yet mask-like and yet he was no
longer handsome Tom Riddle It was as
though his features had been burned and
blurred they were waxy and oddly
distorted and the whites of his nose now
had a permanently bloody look though the
pupils were not yet the slits that Harry
knew they would become it's here we see
that Voldemort is being described as
undergoing his transitions between Tom
and you-know-who it wasn't like he just
killed one person or did some dark magic
one night and then woke up looking like
this the next morning that would have
been quite unfortunate this was years
and years of the darkest magic being not
just used but actually abused and
experimented with so that he could
become immortal mad-eye Moody even says
this to Harry in the order of the
Phoenix don't put your wand there boy
roared Moody what if it ignited better
wizards than you have lost buttocks you
know and as we all know Voldemort leaves
his wand well in the front of his pants
so I mean I'm not gonna jump to any
conclusions here but I mean
hey check out this other excerpt from
the half-blood Prince yet it fitted Lord
Voldemort had seemed to grow less human
with the passing years and the
transformation he had undergone seemed
to me to be only explicable if his soul
was mutated beyond the realms of what we
might call usual evil just like darth
sidious who once was the young
good-looking chancellor palpatine the
use of the dark side over years and
years or dark magic in our case will
inevitably change ones features in
Voldemort's case he murdered so many
people while splitting his soul and
experimenting and abusing dark magic
that had completely changed his looks
the further he split his soul the more
distant from human he became to conclude
the video check these last two bits from
Voldemort himself regarding his use of
dark magic and how it changed him this
one is from the Goblet of Fire I who
have gone further than anybody along the
path that leads to immortality you know
my goal to conquer death and now I was
tested and it appeared that one or more
of my experiments had worked for I had
not been killed though the curse should
have done it and then this one is from
the half-blood Prince I have
experimented I have pushed the
boundaries of magic further perhaps than
they have ever been pushed I think the
more Voldemort splits his soul into the
Horcruxes and the more he succeeded and
failed with dark magic to achieve
immortality it left him scarred and
deformed changing his appearance to
something other than human also in the
books it doesn't say his nose is gone it
just says that he has a flattened nose
with slits for nostrils so he still very
much has a nose it's just very
snake-like thanks for watching today's
video please leave a like if you enjoyed
it and I'll see you all in the next one
until then remember Harry Harry did you
put on able to fire Dumbledore asked
[Music]